merci de nous rejoindre
j'allais dire l'un des combats du MoDem
a toujours été suite François Bayrou
notamment de d'essayer de faire bouger
les lignes à peut-être à sa mesure la
loi Macron Manuel Valls ont essayé de le
faire avec ce projet de loi et à nouveau
j'allais dire les lourdeurs et le
fonctionnement des institutions fait que
non les lignes ne bougent pas et que il
faut avoir recours aux 49,3 pour faire
passer un texte qui froisse une partie
de sa majorité par le dentif vous ce
qu'avec François Bayrou nous disons
depuis presque 3 ans nous disons que
c'est l'histoire de François Hollande
dont on parle aujourd'hui c'est pas
l'histoire de Manuel Valls c'est
l'histoire de François Hollande
c'est-à-dire c'est l'histoire d'un
président qui s'est fait élire sur des
promesses qui ne sont pas exactement
celles de la philosophie de la loi
Macron je parle pas des articles précis
de la loi de Macron mais la philosophie
de l'homme Macron et en réalité ce que
l'on voit aujourd'hui
c'est qu'il y a une partie importante de
la majorité socialiste qui veut être
fidèle à ses promesses et une autre qui
veut évoluer par rapport à ses promesses
et moi ce que je considère c'est que la
majorité aujourd'hui est extrêmement
fragile et quand tout cas il y a un
accroissement de l'écart entre ces deux
camps d'ailleurs accroissement que je
constate
y compris à Bruxelles en ce moment c'est
à dire quand vous regardez la façon dont
réagisse les socialistes français par
rapport au cas grec par rapport à la
question de la discussion entre l'euro
groupe et la Grèce il y a de la même
façon les socialistes les sociodes
démocrates européens qui disent que il
faut pas casser toute la machine de la
négociation entre la Grèce et puis le
regroupe et il y a à côté de cela des
socialistes français que j'appellerai
archaïque excusez-moi de le dire comme
ça mais qui disent derrière la Grèce il
y a la possibilité de mettre fin à une
Europe de l'austérité et on retrouve cet
écart à on le retrouve en France
aujourd'hui et en tout cas ce qui est
vrai c'est qu'en faisant appel au 49.3
ce que François Hollande ne veut pas
faire c'est montrer que il pourrait
avoir une loi qu'il considère comme
importante qui est plus important de
symboliquement qu'elle ne l'est
économiquement qui soit voté autrement
que par des socialistes donc finalement
François Hollande est en il est coincé
dans cette espèce de situation dans la
dans laquelle il est arrivé au pouvoir
il y a trois ans et il essaye de se
démener à travers tout cela et on ne
peut pas dire effectivement à cet égard
que ce soit une victoire loin s'en fout
et je suis pas tout à fait d'accord avec
le professeur Duhamel qui a dit tout à
l'heure que c'était un signe de force
non François Hollande utilise
quand il a gagné la présidentielle on
lui a donné un jeu de cartes ce jeu de
cartes il utilise les cartes les unes
après les autres il a utilisé là un
joker mais rappelez-vous lorsque
Dominique de Villepin a dû faire passer
le CPE par le 49-3 c'était pas bon signe
pour la suite et pas l'expression d'une
force de son gouvernement à l'époque
lucarguna ce que vient de dire est
intéressant parce que la version
officielle c'est et vous l'avez
vous-même redit incertitude à quelques
voix près de ce texte est trop important
pour l'économie française pour prendre
ce risque il y a l'autre interprétation
de Robert Rochat il était important
aussi de ne pas montrer que ce texte
pouvait peut-être inextrémisme passer
grâce à l'apport de voix centriste qui
aurait compensé la défection de voix de
gauche moi j'ai cru comprendre qu'à part
Jean-Christophe Fromentin que je connais
bien pour travailler avec lui sur l'expo
universel 2025 j'ai pas vu beaucoup de
centrices bousculer au portillon mais
j'ai surtout entendu sur sur votre
antenne en à peu près une demi-heure à
la fois l'extrême gauche et l'extrême
droite finalement appeler au même
débauchage vis-à-vis de mes collègues
députés socialistes sont dans leur dans
leur délire commun mais ça leur fait un
point commun de plus et puis surtout
même si il y aura une discussion à voir
en bureau national vis-à-vis de des
collègues qui ont cette fois franchi une
forme de rubiconde dans leur attention
de voter compte plutôt que de s'abstenir
ce débat nous l'aurons pour exiger des
sanctions
de quelle manière le bureau national de
manière collégiale aura ou pas prendre
des sanctions oui il faut le dire et je
vais rappeler je vais vous réclamer ou
vous pensez qu'il faut qu'il y ait des
moi je pense qu'il faut que les députés
socialiste
socialiste au moment où les Français
attendent tant de nous par rapport à ce
quinquennat qui nous faut réussir pas
pour simplement le Parti socialiste et
pour les français en général il faut que
chacun prenne ses responsabilités et
prendre ses responsabilités ce sera
d'avoir ce débat au moment du BTS
on verra moi je suis pour qu'il y ait un
débat un bâton rompu et que les choses
soient très claires soit on est dans le
groupe majoritaire soit on est à côté du
groupe majoritaire et puis par rapport à
celles et ceux qui nous écoutent
il a été utilisé 82 fois le 49-3 sous la
Cinquième République c'est quasi la
totalité des premiers ministres français
qui l'ont utilisés quelques rares
exceptions voyez je vais être objectif
Lionel Jospin François Fillon une fois
la motion de censure a fait basculer un
gouvernement c'est en 62 donc voyez je
n'imagine pas un instant que même si nos
partenaires de gauche que nous avons
dans un contrat de gouvernance réussie à
faire entrer au parlement et à
l'Assemblée nationale en particulier
nous font défaut de plus en plus la
gauche elle est là et la gauche elle
sera de toute manière autour de ce
gouvernement et ce premier ministre
encore une fois tout à fait déterminé à
redresser le pays au-delà de l'image
qu'il pourrait à dominer personnellement
renvoyé il est déterminé et rien ne la
rétra avec son gouvernement et je vais
juste dire à mon collègue qu'il est son
temps qu'il y a beaucoup de députés
socialistes qui ferait fronde pardon de
connaître un peu que ma famille
politique que vous sur les 250 et
quelques députés socialistes j'ai pas le
chiffre tout à fait en tête ils sont un
peu moins de 40 donc voyez il faut là
aussi toute raison la vraie question
c'est pas de savoir si la motion de
censure risque de renforcer le renverser
le gouvernement je n'y crois pas la
vraie question c'est de savoir à l'issue
de cette crise quel est l'état de la
majorité et quelle est sa capacité à
faire des réformes parce que d'ailleurs
la loi Macron moi je vous le dis
franchement si jamais tu es débutantial
je n'aurais pas voté pour je me serais
abstenu tout simplement parce que le
absolu de la République pardon vous
seriez absolument parce que le Président
de la République dans sa bien conférence
de presse nous a laissé entendre
finalement que l'on Macron était la
dernière la première et la dernière et
loi de réformes économique et il me
semble que juste qui se passe
aujourd'hui alors on est à peu près sûr
qu'il y en aura pas d'autres et que des
réformes un peu plus ambitieuses que
celles de Macron dont on a absolument
besoin sur les seuils sociaux sur la
question de l'expérimentation d'un
contrat unique sur différents types de
questions alors ces réformes là
maintenant on est vraiment absolument
convaincu on est sûr que dans les deux
ans qui viennent finalement ça c'est
important est-ce qu'on insiste pas
gérer les affaires courantes
mais on va voir une gestion des affaires
courantes en espérant comme on le dit à
l'Élysée l'alignement des planètes c'est
à dire le cours du dollar la faible
inflation le pétrole et le pétrole face
que par un miracle effectivement on est
un petit peu d'amélioration de la
situation ce dont je ne suis d'ailleurs
pas persuadé Michel file c'est un peu
cela à mon sens notre mal français en
France sur une loi tout le monde appelle
par facilité un peu pareil politique la
loi Macron je rappelle juste que c'est
la loi pour la croissance et pour
l'activité
et que même si on considère que c'est
une loi attrape tout Fourtout une petite
loi je ne comprends pas c'est peut-être
contrairement à des grandes démocraties
en Europe et ailleurs nous n'arriverons
pas sur des sujets pour relancer
l'économie relancer l'emploi là où nous
avons des chiffres importants de chômage
chacun le reconnaît là où quand on
questionne quel que soit l'ovidence
politique les uns et les autres chacun
se dit sur les grands sujets nationaux
on doit pouvoir se retrouver force et de
constater que quand on arrive à
l'Assemblée nationale et bien on
retrouve les petits jeux tactiques de
politique politicienne entre les uns qui
sont sous injonctions de Nicolas Sarkozy
le caporalisme à 98% ils ont plus le
droit de penser les quelques autres
rares Jean-Christophe Romantin essaie de
se démarquer et puis j'ai certains de
mes collègues qui confondent le
redressement du pays avec un congrès du
Parti socialiste oui j'en suis désolé de
votre du côté du MoDem l'usage du 49-3
est toujours vécu lu interprété comme
une forme de coup de force
institutionnel ou en tout cas
dans l'aspect le plus autoritaire
qu'autorise le fonctionnement des
institutions que le problème du 49-3
c'est qu'il règle un problème le jour où
on l'utilise et complique énormément les
choses pour la suite c'est ça la réalité
quand j'entends mon collègue socialiste
et dire que il est étonné parce qu'on
s'intéresse comme ça mais c'est bien une
crise socialiste avec elle on assiste
parce qu'il n'y a que deux cas de figure
on utilise le 49-3 soit c'est parce
qu'on a une majorité vraiment très vous
savez très faible le Premier ministre
est arrivé le majorité ça c'est ça s'est
joué quasiment sur une circonscription
de circonscription et là on sait qu'on
va traîner et donc le 49-3 c'est utile
dans ces cas-là mais c'est pas du tout
la situation politique aujourd'hui le
Parti socialiste a une confortable
majorité l'Assemblée nationale en plus
il s'étalier avec des écologistes avec
lequel il a fait un contrat de
gouvernement lorsqu'il est arrivé
lorsque françoise est arrivé à l'Élysée
donc c'est bien c'est bien ça la crise
donc la crise elle est bien interne à la
majorité totalement elle s'est
complètement à l'intérieur de la
majorité la crise et donc la vraie
question c'est ce 49.3 c'est finalement
une sorte de pommade par rapport à une
plaie qui est là mais sans soigner la
pleine même et la plaie ne va faire que
s'ouvrir encore plus alors vous parlez
du Congrès du Parti socialiste vous avez
raison et en même temps il faut bien que
honnêtement
il faut bien comprendre que le Congrès
du Parti socialiste les Français sont
moquent ce qui intéresse les Français
ça veut dire quoi Manuel Valls serait
plus à l'aise au modem qu'il ne l'est au
Parti socialiste mais non que je vois
chez mon collègue député européen un
discours qui me qui me sied on peut
avoir des points communs je dis
simplement que la question du Congrès du
Parti socialiste risque de devenir dans
les mois qui viennent le nouvel comment
dire du talon non pas de nouvelles
étalon mais mais mais le le leur c'est à
dire que on va se on va se positionner
sur le Congrès du Parti socialiste et
même peut-être vous les journalistes
vous allez interroger le pouvoir sur la
façon dont il va gérer le Congrès du
Parti socialiste alors que la vraie
question c'est le chômage vrai question
c'est la situation économique dans notre
pays moi je pense que le vrai problème
le vrai problème c'est un gouvernement
socialiste a priori ça se veut une
majorité sociale et comment peut-on être
social lorsque il y a 600 000 chômeurs
de plus depuis qu'on arrive aux affaires
sans du tout rupture c'est une
continuité absolue et la montée de la
pauvreté et la montée de la grande
pauvreté et la montée du chômage de
longueur
et malgré tout ce que vous dites sur le
constat économique et social que je
partage vous auriez été prêt à vous
abstenir parce que c'est pas logique
mais si parce que parce que la loi
Macron et c'est ça le pire dans toute
cette affaire c'est que la loi Macron
était une loi qui possédait un certain
nombre de choses qui n'étaient pas
forcément qui est intéressant dans
certains cas de figure bon mais qui
n'allaient pas en plus au cœur du
problème pour sortir du pays de la
calandre des choses intéressantes
du Parti socialiste est encore plus fort
c'est-à-dire que vous arrivez à vous
déchirer c'était quoi les mesures qui
qui trouvaient grâce à vos yeux c'est
extrêmement simple c'est il faut tester
le contrat unique pour sortir du chômage
dans lequel on est aujourd'hui si on ne
met pas en place quelque chose il faut
mettre en place une simplification
absolument considérable je vous signale
au passage que la loi Macron est une loi
qui complexifie beaucoup plus partout
parce que quand une majorité est faible
et qu'il faut faire passer dans les
amendements tel ou tel type de réforme
on complexifie regardez la question de
l'ouverture du dimanche l'ouverture du
dimanche mise à part les zones
touristiques internationales moi je vous
dis je suis totalement pour ça c'est
clair c'est lisible il y a un
gouvernement qui décide le boulevard
Haussmann à Paris c'est une zone
internationale de tourisme c'est clair
sinon pour le reste toute la complexité
de l'ouverture du dimanche les 200 cas
d'exonération
tout est toujours présent donc il faut
simplifier il faut un contrat unique il
faut effectivement que l'apprentissage
soit massivement réorienté vers les
chômeurs et non pas dépenser à tort et à
travers comme c'est le cas aujourd'hui
il faut une réforme territoriale qui
fasse des économies or la réforme
territoriale dont les parlementaires
vont se saisir dans quelques jours on le
sait bien elle le fera aucune économie
de dépense publique voilà c'était ça les
vrais sujets alors autant de concessions
fait au députés pour les amadouer et
tout ça pour finir par un 42 3 est-ce
que Macron et valent ce soir doivent pas
se dire mais on aurait juste passé en
force le film et au moins d'ailleurs
peut-être un syndrome de mesure sur
lesquels il a fallu de temporiser serait
leur force le passage en force c'est pas
la marque de fabrique de Manuel Valls je
rappelle que la démocratie s'appuie sur
le dialogue le compromis le consensus
ensuite je rappelle aussi à ceux qui
nous écoutent que le texte qui va être
adopté aujourd'hui avec la procédure du
49-3 c'est un texte qui est passé de 100
article qui était le taxe initial du
gouvernement à 200 articles qui est le
produit d'une cofabrication de la loi et
donc ce qui se passe aujourd'hui c'est
la première lecture à la sembler
nationale il y aura les débats comme la
Rapée Gérard longue et mon confrère
au Sénat et je vais répondre à mon
collègue du MoDem il y a pas de crise au
Parti socialiste et la preuve en est sur
ce qui se passe en terme de
rassemblement autour du premier
secrétaire sortant dans le cadre
justement du Congrès qu'il y a un
problème dans la majorité qui se
répercute même dans les futurs élections
départementales oui un problème avec les
partenaires aujourd'hui mais nous notre
travail c'est de rassembler autre point
d'actualité on va en parler tout de
suite avec Thomas clé c'est la cour
d'appel qui vient d'annuler l'arbitrage
tapis et va reprendre le dossier
première Rochefort le modèle a été en
pointe vous pas besoin de me souffler
mais une fois de plus François Bayrou a
été et je crois que vous pouvez en
témoigner et je dois dire
malheureusement qu'il a été le seul vers
la classe politique et avec Jean-Pierre
Levade qui effectivement
était avec nous et nous avons été les
seuls je dois absolument confirmer ce
que vient de dire monsieur Rochefort
François Bayrou a été au départ de cette
affaire celui qui a dénoncé le scandale
plus haut que tout le monde et qu'il a
porté médiatiquement alors il y a eu une
ou deux autres personnes il y a eu
Charlesbourg
il y a même eu Jérôme Cahuzac il faut le
rappeler aujourd'hui puisqu'on connaît
son destin par la suite mais Jérôme
caddussac a été le seul socialiste à
dénoncer également cette affaire dès
l'origine ça fait pas beaucoup hein
trois parlementaires François Pérou
n'était pas parlementaires trois
parlementaires sur cette affaire ça fait
pas beaucoup pour redresser une quand
même une situation qui était tout à fait
anormale merci beaucoup de ma clé on
peut lire d'ailleurs parce que vous avez
profité de l'occasion un code de
l'arbitrage commenté ça expliquera
beaucoup de choses absolument à la fois
de cet arbitrage là et du fait que vous
l'ayez d'emblée
merci beaucoup allez le 5 à 7 continue
dans un instant le journal